Frost thanks for the shout of breakfast
the what do you think or what do you
make of the idea that in you kick target
seats there are massive posters of Alex
Salmond and Nicola Sturgeon paid for by
the Conservative Party toy suit please
see this as a way to kind of get back
lost lost stories I mean the air of
desperation about the Cameron campaign
he seems to spend more the campaign now
begging you get both us to come back to
him but he does send in the country what
he actually stands for and it's not
gonna work it might reinforce his own
vote but it's not gonna work people that
have left the Conservatives and come to
you can have done so because they feel
completely left out promises on a
referendum that you didn't deliver
immigration super zero controls wind
farm springing up all over the country
and for many of them gay marriage being
brought in despite it not being a
manifesto commitment plays being rid of
Neff Cameron on going back but he also
misunderstands but actually the majority
of you get voters having come from
conservatives anywhere maybe four out of
ten of our voters of Hamelin
conservatives but a lot of come from
elsewhere but it's a potent message for
the sorts of people that have come from
the Conservatives to you clip that are
concerned about Brussels you can see me
you can see why they're doing it they
think that they're the sorts of people
that would be most concerned about the
idea of a SNP pants government but
enough what he might be doing with these
outbursts if he might be driving more
labor voters into our arms because I
think you know if you are a Labour voter
and your old labor and you Patrick I
think you're asking
you concerned about immigration then I
think you know for labor vote alike that
the threat of an SME coalition really
worries them so so and we are teaming
directly to labor voters saying that is
this what you really want what you
believe that's you making the same
aren't you a similar argument but well
the argument we're making is that if
your old labor with those priorities
there is no chance of them even being
discussed it Nicola Sturgeon is Anna
coalition and it looks to me like she
would probably wear the drowsies when
you look at the campaign so far when
when we took we talked in Clapton after
the by-election your by-election and you
told me you were indifference to the
idea over Miliband Premiership or David
Cameron friendship that's changed now to
Nate's Oh favourite David Cameron for
what I'm indifferent in the sense that
it won't make it huge deal of difference
I mean you're running a small business
in this town it's irrelevant losing
downstream because in effect in the
world to the lawyers would affect your
business and made in Brussels not here
so we are voting for change of
management as opposed to a change of
government the one difference is this
what I got wrong is I thought that
Miliband which would probably promised a
referendum a bit reluctantly he's chosen
not to do so so on that basis from the
perspective that we would rather see
David Cameron was the biggest party
though we don't trust him at all told
the referendum on free and fair terms
but David Cameron is the biggest party
with enough with enough you give him
he's to hold his feet to the fire his
glass the best option now in terms of
enough MPs
you know it's um you were pretty bullish
about six months ago 20 and be something
like that
I know you've modulated you know do you
know what I said six months ago to you
was we were target dozens of seats yes
that's exactly what we're doing the
reality is we're realistic for you're
talking you have I haven't gotten my
crystal ball none of us got a mix team
but all I know is we've got nearly a
fortnight's ago I think the public are
getting forward to death with the sheer
negativity of this campaign every single
morning you know it's the tourists a
label would bankrupt so it's Labor same
as always it would close down the health
service we get various spending pledges
made but clearly aren't funded and I
think the public looking was have been
different I'm very upbeat about you
creates positive messages in positive
solutions I'm upbeat about the manifesto
which is now beginning to reach a wider
sections of the community and I think
we're in a position in the last few
weeks we'll be concerned from there but
in trying to ride two horses right and
left you've said now that you'd prefer
david cameron's to be Prime Minister
oh how because only because he has at
least albeit half-heartedly promised to
referendum there is no other reason than
that if you take that out
the differences between the two frankly
are pretty minimal but how do you hope
you're giving up on the Heywood and
Middleton labor strategy then without
now with the labor voters in the north
they don't want David Cameron is good or
good lord I'll be the hot people next
year do you know we are fighting lots of
labour seats of a northern England
people vote do you get know that our
priority is to get back control of our
country and get back control of our
borders and whoever we have to do a deal
with to make that happen we'll do it in
this swing labour conservative labour
targets conservative well you're not
going to win where there's two or three
thousand you could photos it could make
the difference what's your message to
them though UK because actually this
isn't just about what I'm receipts we
win this is about the number of votes we
get this is about a percentage boat
share it's also about
receipts in which becomes second because
I'm not just thinking about maybe seven
I'm thinking about a longer-term
strategy 2022
I mean don't forget the SNP in 2010 had
a handful of seats in Westminster and
just look where they are now and I feel
if you keep gets over this hurdle
clearly with a big national vote share
not only will the party be in a position
to be a really big player by 2020 but I
also think every vote you kick gets will
fuel the argument for the a genuine
electoral reform in this country some
sorts of proportional representation
I see I mean you know years ago Blair
asked Roy Jenkins to have to hold a
commission on electoral reform Jenkins
came back with a proposal of Cordain V+
basically you get two ballot papers one
you still keep the man and woman there
represents your town but there is a
second ballot paper that makes you think
well if you live in a safe Tory see you
know when your labor vote so why not
bother to vote this system would
reengage the public in voting and under
that system you you could think that you
would get dozens of you to have 15 and
16 percent of the vote wouldn't mean a
lot more seats on what I think actually
to be honest with you if it was that
system arcus then it would be a lot
harder 15 percent okay let's think about
some of your manifesto closer so me to
you to remind myself first well the
first things you say is the Chancellor
has failed to stick to the 2010 promise
to wipe out the deficit what would you
have cut more oil taxes
let's just be clear the coalition was
formed that ceremony in the garden on
that lovely behaved
2010 with one objective that was to
reduce the deficit to zero it is still
running at ninety billion pounds a year
and I think more stunningly the real
elephant in the room in this debate in
in his election debate than a watchdog
well they doubled the national debt in
five years so you're suggesting you you
would have cut more yes ten billion
pounds a year minimum on the foreign aid
budget ten billion pounds a year
we knew contributions for billion pounds
a year on the enormous white elephant
that's for this Parliament you're
suggesting that they fail over the past
five years what would you've come
they've increased the foreign aid budget
radically they've increased our EU
contributions they've increased spending
on things that we as a party doesn't
believe in necessary so scrapping the
hs2 vanity project well you know that
the last manifesto was hugely
enthusiastic about high-speed rail well
luckily luckily the chaplet wrote that
depicted to the Tory party on these to
say okay actually he wasn't in favor of
hs2 he was in favor of better real
communications across the UK so you'd be
against a chest wall as well for
seemingly aegis-1 had to be both no we
have a channel tunnel so in favor of
high-speed rail to your constituency and
to your current job in Brussels what
well not connected well under the Ninth
Ward actually we'd reached a point where
frankly it was a bit of an embarrassment
not to have I speed rail coming across
from Paris and Brussels so it's been
balanced but not time high-speed rail
coming across from Paris but it's not
embarrassing to have high-speed rail you
Kathleen are two major cities if you
catch a train now the Paddington depends
on it takes five hours and 11 minutes it
was quicker than that before the First
World War there are parts of the country
that are completely disconnected but for
modest sums of money can lead to
upgrades to the line the French have got
my speed rail you know the current HST
proposal will cost nine times per mile
what the TGV in France our car it's
badly costed it's the wrong project and
anyway Manchester's only two hours away
so you want higher speed rail but not
what I was sipping forget I want better
rail connectivity which can be done
incredibly cheaply compared to a project
that could cost 50 60 or 70 billion
pounds and to which the private sector
is unlikely to put in a penny because
these things will never be lose money so
you gonna take five and a half billion
away from Scottish bother
yes
who's given up on Scotland no I want to
know do burglars
I thought it was extraordinary to see
the three party leaders in in in in the
face of the Scottish terror saying
unconditionally they would maintain the
Barnett formula the method by which the
Scots get 15% more per head the mean
vinegar frankly they just the penis
Scottish nationalism when you appease
people like that they just get hungry at
that we are not committed to it we think
it's unfair but that would mean severe
cuts force for the Scottish people yes
they wanted devolution and frankly I'm
what why should people sitting in this
cafe pay their taxes to give Scottish
kids free tuition please the families to
have no prescription charges it isn't
right it isn't fair we've had enough of
shoveling money over Hadrian's Wall so
the Conservatives are now sort of
adopting this mantra of English
manifestos and things are you sort of
competing with English national high
water is just the hilarious isn't it you
know basically every time you kick
places a flag in the sand and since this
is where we want to go this is what they
used to be done they won't try an eighth
us and why don't we brand yourself as
English National Party because we're the
only political policy with elected
representation in all four corners of
the United Kingdom the only party you
know we have a net we we have an MEP the
Scotland became them in a whisker of
topping the polls in Wales our Welsh
polling is just as strong as our English
polling and have a member of the stormer
assembly in the line we are a United
Kingdom Independence Party but we
recognize with what's happened with the
relation but actually a fair deal needs
to be struck friendly okay
okay well let's talk about your
signature policy which is obviously
leaving the European Union you have said
in your manifesto the you will
renegotiate reciprocal visa arrangements
with friendly country
so that leaves open the possibility that
you won't get them and that we'll need a
visa to go to countries in your world
do you know something getting visas
online now is really very very quick
thing to do it takes a matter of seconds
it isn't this isn't about queuing up you
know outside of foreign embassy all of
this could be done very quickly very
easily online so you could contemplate
that with a country like Spain or France
that we'd have to get a visa well I
think there are countries there are
countries in the European Union there
are many there are many ways rather
similar to us similar educational
standards similar health care provisions
relatively similar levels of wealth and
actually you know the first 30 years of
the European Union the free movement of
people was an honest politically a
completely non-issue what went wrong and
I predicted this at the time - to a
chorus of abuse which of course I'm
getting quite used to what I predicted
was but if you let in 10 former
communist countries many of whom have
not actually made the full transition to
being western-style democracies and
where the minimum wage take Romania for
example is about about 10% of what it is
in this country that you were
necessarily then you know have a huge
migration of people and it does not make
sense for Britain to have an open door
with countries like Romania and Bulgaria
but you can't guarantee that your
policies wound
- the need for visas just to travel the
European Union 77 percent of people in
this country want us to have proper
further control I can quite easily see
reciprocal deals with countries of a
similar standing to ourselves but with
some countries things will change and
yes there will be the inconvenience from
going online to getting a visa that is a
very smooth price to pay to get control
back of our borders and to behave in
game and only then to put in place on
Australian standpoint system so that we
have a skills-based
immigration policy and one that doesn't
discriminate against the Commonwealth in
favor of Europe what we can judge people
simply on their abilities regardless of
where they come from so you think
actually these are big historical
moments and the idea of a referendum in
2017 you look at the demographics of
who's fallen against the EU who likes
the purple Passport maybe an enough
material like that freedom and there's a
clear old young splits here and this may
actually be your one and only if you
look at that passport that British
passport what are the first two words on
it so there are four hundred eighty five
million people effectively have that
Passport I think that's unacceptable
and if any what's interesting about
about you think it is for you silly
polling and now ya know any what's
interesting about Euroskeptic opinion
and about the UK code it is getting
younger we noticed it in the Rochester
by-election and certainly here you know
in this constituency if you come out
with me today on the streets you'll be
very surprised you get both is getting
younger and younger and are you prepared
for two years of uncertainty and
economic problems we saw what happened
ahead of the Scottish referendum with an
EU referendum is that fair price to pay
I think the difference is this that
whilst the Scots had that referendum I
don't think for the Scottish National
Party be phenomenally had a viable
alternative
that they were saying the oil would
bring in seven point nine billion
sterling in taxes every year actually
with the price of course it is it would
be just I know hang on you have to fund
your social care yeah a sovereign wealth
fund based on fracking which hasn't
given a penny yeah well that's a long
we're modeling ourselves on Norway and
that's the long-term aspiration short
term but is it short term that can't
help people but it is a long term
manifester yes and it's something it's
not gonna raise a penny for social
something it's something we should have
done back in the nineteen seventies it's
a great mistake that we didn't say yes
long term absolutely that is what we
want to do but in terms of this
uncertainty argument salmon didn't have
an answer to the currency didn't have an
answer sit through the over reliance on
oil much of which actually was in
English territory waters not Scottish
waters we have a very simple answer our
answer is this Britain is now the
biggest export market in the world will
be eurozone no they just hit the
motorcar trade for example they sell us
nearly a million motorcars a year more
than we sell them and I rather go along
with the former Labour Minister Lord
Digby Jones who said you could negotiate
a free trade deal within 24 hours
because the German car industry would
demand nothing less there is no other
part of the world in which the argument
gets made but you have to be in
political union know that we're buying
some widgets from each other you on the
same issue you've called this area we're
very close to now so you keep has
referred to this area we're very close
to now as a No Deal I haven't said that
much so you do not think that this area
is a no-go area for I I've learned a
lesson which is if I was to think that
and make that comment you know I would
be so handed by the
literally correct media class but it's
not worth the progress of what we do do
you think it though absolutely I tell
you what we do would go and ask people
out there what they pay all right I've
been already I would a visit and see
people said no there was a Polish
husband of a planet based English woman
who is very proud of some of the changes
this is the point anything well if there
you are so if someone was in all of them
and there's some people in the shops you
weren't so
I have a designated roles in grafton
bill and people say to me we would not
move down that Street at night that's
their view this is fundamentalism
because are you appealing to a kind of
old 1950s view of this country the
reality of this area is that the holiday
trade abandoned its and then eventually
migrants came in and filled in cheap
property it's not the migrants fault she
blamed the migrants for not least the
fact the people started to go to Spain
on holiday a reason for an area like
this to be filled up with Eastern
European migrants identity first you're
saying it's their fault it's just oh oh
please please get one thing clear I've
never blamed any mining for anything I
blame the Westminster politicians for
allowing this to happen he's
irresponsible and stupid to allow
unlimited numbers of people to come into
this country many of them don't have
skills or even speak the language that
doesn't make sense but the fact that
they came here was a result of other
factors not the empty and cheap property
as a result they came here is because
they've come from countries they lived
under the yoke of communism they
suffered racial discrimination these
people in many of their countries on a
level like most British people even
understand so they want to come to a
country where they're going to have a
better life and I completely understand
that
but the problem is but large numbers of
people coming to Britain so that they
can have a better life has not meant a
better life the millions of good people
and the dust want a point where you
actually have to say we need to put the
interests of our own people
there's people here that from those
communities some of them from Roma
communities from Eastern Europe who come
to Britain and come to be schooled in
South annex and one of them came
headboards and has made something and
thinks Britain is the most amazing
country for that because they were
suffering racial discrimination in their
home countries
are you proud of the fact that Britain
is educated am not that guy unlike you
I've visited the Roma communities
I visited the Roma settlements I've done
it and put barrettes I've got any Sofia
livin without individual deepest world
Romania I'd sing about living for 5
million Roman live and they do suffer a
massive degree of discrimination and I
feel very so able but we cannot have a
open unlimited birth
I want to have a reasonable balanced
sensible immigration policy based on the
Australian star point system and we do
that by 2020 when you cover the next
general election immigration won't even
be an issue because it seems to as much
of an issue as you might have expected
in this election anyway yeah but you
spend too much time in London and if you
actually get out and meet real people
you will find it is the number one issue
on their lips and I mean that it is
immigration and the effects of it on
people's health and the economy is what
exactly look at the Health Service the
population is gone through that's why
immigrants what it isn't it isn't it
isn't it appalling that we're not
training enough alone nurses
extraordinary that without doing that
our population I mean our population has
risen since the early 1990s by nearly 10
million and we now have fewer gp's per
head than any other country so 10 more
tip in German with the housing crisis we
have a housing crisis build more houses
we need to be work we need to build one
new house every 7 minutes just okay with
current levels of migration this doesn't
make sense a booming number in the
population
oh isn't it marvelous we've got a bigger
GDP and of course we've got a bigger GDP
we've got more people do we have a
higher GDP per capita no um you want to
exempts vehicles over 25 years from VD
that's is it is it I tell you what the
disaster for the environment just not
here
there also is the wind turbines not only
are they big ugly but we have to
subsidize them hugely the taxpayers
money they give us expensive electricity
and what it's meant let's focus on it
let's focus on tax cuts to top gear are
you a wealthy enough classic cars I
won't do about the environment right so
what we've done is to give our
manufacturers expensive energy what have
they done
left gone to India and many other
countries and while they produce their
products
with much lower environmental
regulations and then have to ship them
all back actually many of our so-called
green policies have led to higher global
co2 emissions not lower and against that
you know a few thousand classic cars
he's actually well small this year
listen intriguing priority though for
the country right now well this is
something this event this issue is
something that of course the British
Parliament can't rule up because this is
all decided in Europe and we have put
things in the manifesto but we could do
but only if we're free from simple tell
me about tampons well there we are
there we are absolutely I wasn't
expecting to be talking tampons resumes
from no was I really but our wit we're a
broadly based policy yeah so what we've
said is we could remove the 80 from
sanitary products but of course we're
not allowed to do that because the
European Union would tell me how's it
going personally to all you hear it so
none of this you could do really well in
terms of the number of votes and if you
don't win here it will be a failure
obviously personally you won't be leader
I'm confident not complacent
has it been quite tough I mean some
people argue when are your best in the
debates I think that's true and I think
I think that is true and I've no I don't
think I think I think in my desperation
for you get to succeed I don't think I
got the balance of my working day right
just massively overdoing it I'm now
being a bit selective and I feel I've
got within and bigger back and I've got
the bounce back my optimism back alright
and I just look at how we're doing in
our King can campaigning seats I'm a
look at the cameras returns coming in
and what clear to me is this our
national vote share is holding
rock-solid but what's happening is our
vote sharing
down in some of those battlegrounds when
labour and Tory are fighting very hard
and we're not quite up to their level
our vote share in some of those seats is
dropping as you because Sunday for
labour some gave the Tory but in the
seats in which we're doing well and in
the seats in which as a perception
Lincoln might win our boat shares going
up so I am actually with two weeks to go
frizzy bullish and how's it personally I
mean this is your national figures the
first time is I remember in 2011 the
European in Brussels doing the eurozone
story and and in four years things have
totally transformed for you I mean
frankly you know it seems ridiculous but
I think we were fighting to get on the
telly at that point talking about the
collapse and you seems quite excited by
the eurozone collapse yes in because it
proved things have changed so much in
four years is that proof personally a
bit of a toil I don't for one moment
regret giving up when my own job running
my own company and the prospect of us I
think having perhaps made quite a lot of
money in the commodity boom had every
got it for one minute I've followed my
heart I've followed my passions I've
done something I wanted to do and you
know what most of it is just huge huge
one last thing you refer to the
metropolitan liberal elite a lot and
it's in your manifesto yet but you are
metropolitan you a fan of Gladstone the
liberal and I would argue you've just
mentioned that you could have made
millions in the comic good what I do but
I did you could metropolitan liberal
elites no I'm really a country boy at
point number one and secondly I think of
the current political leaders but I am
able to mix you think you were Gladstone
your nipple well I think in in terms of
wanting a smaller state and not wanting
government to decide and Mike
our lives yes you'll fit less than your
favorite Prime Minister which probably
your favorite Prime Minister past
hundred years well I mean we're just a
couple of miles away from the harbor
from which the little fishing boats and
ten barges went across the bring back
the British Army says go to church I'm
surprised